Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call.
Let's just jump right in.
But I don't have a whole lot of questions submitted.
So if you're thinking, excuse me,
chant that and make it as soon as you can.
So I don't have too soon.
Okay, let's jump right to the questions.
What's the difference between lumbro kinase and nano kinase
and the pancreatic enzymes that Dr. Gonzalez used for cancer?
So it's the type of enzymes.
So there's different enzymes that break down different things.
The enzymes that Dr. William Ellie used.
And then Dr. Gonzalez learned from him.
And then I actually learned from Dr. Gonzalez.
So Dr. Gonzalez was one of my instructors.
A great guy.
And he was more of a cancer clinician.
Dr. Kelly was an orthodontist who actually helped heal his cancer
by using proteolytic enzymes.
So proteolytic enzymes are enzymes that break down proteins.
And then there are enzymes that break down mainly carbohydrates
like amylase.
And enzymes that mainly break down fats like lipase.
There's a lot of different forms of enzyme.
Lumbro kinase and nano kinase are known to help kind of clear the blood
and clean the blood.
Atocardase really got its start in helping work a goblet placking
on the inside of arteries.
The problem is that when they've done studies on some of these,
some studies are positive and some studies are negative.
They don't really show much improvement at all.
But I really do believe this is just my opinion that some studies were set to be negative,
meaning that they used a poor source of nutrient in their study.
That's just my opinion.
They were purposely, they were funded by the pharmaceutical companies to fail.
And they failed.
But I do think that, you know, there are good forms of enzymes.
There are bad forms of enzymes.
Enzymes are a very heat sensitive.
So you've got to be careful if you have a bottle of enzymes.
If you leave about your car in the summertime and they heat up at your car,
you probably destroyed most of the enzymes in that bottle.
So you want to keep your enzymes protected from heat.
You want to keep all your nutrients protected from excess heat,
but definitely enzymes.
Enzymes will degrade quickly.
I've said in other podcasts that there's some supplements that basically have,
you know, an endless shelf life.
What would be minerals?
Really don't degrade over time.
If you took a bottle of a good quality mineral from a good supplement company,
30 years ago, it probably have 98% efficacy too as well.
And antioxidants don't degrade.
So if you have supplements that use antioxidants in them,
some supplement companies put, basically put canalace and superoxid.
Disritace basically in every product.
One of those companies would be biotics research.
They use, it doesn't make them a better company,
but they tend they use kind of as their base.
They use canalace and superoxid.
Disritace.
So it's in literally every supplement that they have.
Well, one of the positives of that,
it basically extends the shelf life of that product to, you know,
decades beyond its expiration time.
Well, minerals are, excuse me, enzymes are not that way.
They're a little degrade over time.
They're the most easily thing easy thing to degrade with heat.
And enzymes are specific to what they will break down.
So lumbarokites and that kind of say have blog posts on both of those,
what they do, how they're used to the body.
You would not, you know, take high doses of lumbarokites.
To break down the, you know, the way slayer around a cancer,
you'd use proteolytic enzymes.
So it's just the right use of an enzyme.
So you'd use it, if you try to use a digestive enzyme to help break down food,
you'd use a more broad spectrum digestive enzyme like US enzymes,
digestimes, plus, or our clear digest,
which is a more broad spectrum enzyme to break down food,
but you wouldn't use our clear digest to help break down,
as a high dose to break down the, the way slayer around a cancer,
you'd use a proteolytic enzyme.
So you're just going to use your enzymes wisely.
And I will say, you know, at the time that Dr. William Kelly
was using enzymes that was back in the 1960s,
there just wasn't very many enzymes on the market.
So he settled on the pancreatic pork enzymes,
and that's what Dr. Gonzalez used was the allergy research brand pancreatic pork enzymes.
Now, the negative of that is that you take on a ton of them,
and he would use in his enzyme therapy,
people would be taking upwards of 150 capsules a day.
It's a lot of capsules to swallow.
This could be very difficult.
So there's some better enzymes on the market now that have more concentrates
you could take less capsules.
I have estrogen receptor, ER positive breast cancer,
the two drugs that they have prescribed to me are lentusol and RISM medicine.
What supplements do I continue taking?
So you, you wouldn't change, you know, some people when they go on an aerobotase inhibitor,
they think, well, am I so good off any of the natural aerobotase inhibitors?
And in one sense, that makes sense.
You can do that.
Firstly, I wouldn't.
I would still be taking my natural aerobotase inhibitor.
So they answered this question and I wouldn't change my protocol based upon these two medications
I would state to my protocol.
Dr. Connors, regarding our conversation on Monday about my labs and my thyroid numbers,
my thyroid doctor asked about maybe thyroid cancer possibly reoccurring.
I want your thoughts on that.
Scary.
Thank you.
So, um, so that person's thyroid numbers, if I recall, they had elevated TSH,
over a hundred.
So TSH is thyroid stimulated horrible.
That's created in the, in the, um, to a Terry gland.
They had depressed, depressed, reverse T3.
And they had depressed T3 and depressed T4, free T3 and free T4.
And negative TPO antibodies, negative thyroid globulin antibodies.
That is the picture perfect diagnostic scenario of primary hypothyroidism.
So it's, it would be very rare for a person with thyroid cancer.
You have any abnormalities in their thyroid numbers.
Either their T3, T4 typically thyroid cancer doesn't affect T3 and T4,
but thyroid cancer does not affect TSH.
So when you have elevated TSH, depressed T3,
re T3, depressed free T4, um, negative under antibodies.
That is a picture perfect example of primary hypothyroidism.
There's always that one in a million chance that, you know, it could be something else.
Uh, to get, uh, if you want to rule it out, rule it out,
get a, uh, scan an MRI of the thyroid gland and you could rule it out.
Typically, if cancer, thyroid gland was reoccurried, you would see, um,
you know, you would, you would have other palpatory findings as well.
But if you want to be careful in ruling out, I would, I would not say,
those numbers are indicative of thyroid cancer re-curried based upon the numbers.
Um, doesn't mean that something might not be going on, but I wouldn't,
but how that didn't even cross my mind that, that is, uh, you know,
a, um, um, a side of thyroid cancer.
There's lots of standard blood work and, you know,
specific to an organ or something like that blood work that you could run.
That gives you all of a sudden, you know, like, it's not diagnostic of anything,
but it's an ominous sign kind of gives you clues.
So, for instance, you know, some ominous signs in your complete metabolic panel would be,
wow, my cholesterol has always run about 205 to 220.
And I was really excited because I ran my, um, complete metabolic panel.
So my cholesterol was down to 115.
Sorry, but that's not, that's the band sign.
So if you have your cholesterol plummet, um, so if the person wasn't taking lipitor
or anything like that, well, even if you're taking lipitor, it shouldn't fill up at 100 points.
So, but having low cholesterol isn't ominous sign.
Of course, you're 13-year-old cousin who goes, it doesn't complete metabolic panel.
And maybe they have cholesterol of 115 that can be their normal cholesterol.
But if your normal cholesterol is 180 to, you know, 220 or something like that,
and you go and you run it and it's down in the low 100,
that's an ominous sign of liver cancer.
Your ominous sign in standard blood work would be, um, depressed, um,
or changes in your liver function tests like your alkaline phosphatase, your AST,
your ALP, your albumin, your globulin levels.
Those are just different ominous signs.
They're not, they're not diagnostic of anything specific without looking at other things.
But typically, with the thyroid, a person isn't going to have abnormal thyroid levels
and then the person goes to the doctor and goes, well, this could be a sign of cancer.
We need to investigate.
No, the signs of cancer with the thyroid will be palpitory findings,
would be a mass, would be something we need to do an ultrasound done,
and then do a scan of, and then do a biopsy.
So, um, that's, um, would be my take on that.
How often should I use the right ion pro wave to detox heavy metals or other things?
Is there such a thing as too much?
Well, I never suggest using the ion pro wave more than one time a day.
That would be the maximum.
Once a day would be the maximum on that.
Does the ion pro wave, first of all, let's take a step back.
Does the ion pro wave really help detoxify heavy metals?
Um, yeah, I can.
Are you going to pull a whole bunch of heavy metals out of your feet and into the water?
Not really.
No.
Um, ion pro wave is understand the right ion pro wave is putting frequencies in.
And by putting frequencies through there, you are affecting tissue.
And you do have some detoxification through your feet.
But all that change in color in the water isn't just a bunch of gum coming out of your body.
So let's not misinterpret that.
Now, there's other machines called ion cleanses.
There's a company called ion cleanse that started that machine.
Now, that's using that's actually it's called an ion cleanse because it's ionizing the water and a positive charge for a period of time is a negative charge.
Typically, it's set at a 70 30 setting positive charge to negative charge.
Therefore, having that charge of the water is pulling the opposite ion out of your tissue more so than the ion pro wave.
So ion pro wave does a little bit of ionization.
That's why it's going to pull some things, but not as much as that other machine called the ion cleanse.
So it makes one that is similar to that.
But that machine that company has both those companies have a very good reputation making quality equipment.
They've been doing it for years.
But there can be benefit to using some like that to help help pull heavy metals.
But quite honestly, most heavy metals in your body are launched into your tissues.
They're not circulating in your bloodstream unless you have a cute metal toxicity.
So if you did a blood test and you did your testing for heavy metals in your blood test, they would be negative.
Unless you had a cute exposure.
So meaning that somebody who just tried to poison you with arsenic and you got really super sick.
When did the emergency room?
What do you mean something they would normally do because most people don't get poisoned, right?
But if for some reason, you had a very astute doctor that maybe listen to a family member that came in and said,
my mom's husband, I think he killed his last wife or something.
I am crazy story and watch too much date line or something.
But and then they tested for that, then you would have elevated arsenic in the blood.
And the treatment would be to put you on IV, EDTA immediately.
So IV chelation immediately to pull that out of your blood.
And unless you had this this grow test exposure, this high exposure to a heavy metal, where you get heavy metals is is lower dose.
And lower dose heavy metals, they're not going to stay in your blood for very long.
It's going to be pushed to your tissues.
And then it can, you know, be pushed anywhere.
So can be pushed into cells.
It can be pushed across the blood drain barrier, especially this small particle heavy metals like you'd find in vaccines.
That's one of the major reasons why I'm so adamantly against vaccines is because the aluminum mercury that they do use as an adjuvant in the vaccine.
They say really they the pharmaceutical company says there's no hard no foul in those because they're so small, they're nano particles.
Well, nano particles of aluminum are even are far worse because they will cross the blood right barrier.
Matter of fact, it's just really interesting.
Just reading an article today about how nano heavy medical metals are one major cause of neurological tables in Alzheimer's disease.
So neurological tables in Alzheimer's disease can be made up of heavy metals.
It can be made up of biotoxins like H by Laura and Borrelia burgodorphy and chlamydia pneumonia.
Those are the three that they found in the study of biotoxins and then heavy metals, aluminum mercury, most likely due to from vaccinations and these tables block neuronal flow and conductivity.
And that's what is also worse disease.
So, you know, heavy metals are a bad player in our body heavy metals are also one of the top four along with H by Laura causes of epithelial inflammation endothelial inflammation causing cordary heart disease.
So yeah, we want to get rid of heavy metals, but they're lodged in these tissues.
So the way you get rid of them is go back and look at the severed phases of detoxification pathways and you're supporting all these phases of detoxification.
And you really need to use ultimately a key later that's going to grab on to help pull out of the tissues and you have to be do this slowly and be supporting all the phases of detoxification.
So that you're not just pulling about a one tissue and it can't get through the liver phase one phase two pathways because those are already blocked because you're not supporting that they already detoxing too many other things and then they just get deposited somewhere else.
So, it's really important to follow that pathway.
That's why so being on sawdust because sawdust is helping you detox through your skin and bypass the liver.
So, I am probably can help so don't give me wrong you have that tool use it but don't count on that alone is all I'm saying.
There's the last question you guys so if you have any questions, chat them in.
I was recently diagnosed with Grover's disease.
Grover's disease has nothing to do with the muppet character.
It's a skin rash typically in older man where you get this itchy extreme itchy players just as this person is saying they're looking for a right program for this.
I look to look at what you really want to look at is for this is anti-histimates.
So, if you look up Grover's disease you won't find anything that is the known cause.
However, Grover's disease along with many other skin rashes that have no known causes that are idiopathic are due to histamine reactions due to exposure of toxins.
So, with a person that has cancer you're exposed.
I think this person just in surgery you're exposed to chemicals in the you're exposed to tons of garbage they had to put you up with chemicals you're put out with drugs you're you know those things build up in your system and you end up with a histamine reaction to those things.
So, Grover's all gets back to detoxification pathways going back to the 7 faces of detox.
Think about anti-histamine type things and remember for cancer patient you know you know there's some drugs that can be good for a cancer patient and one of them is the anti-histamine over the counter anti-histamines.
So, with a counter anti-histamine if it helps with this it can it will also help decrease histamines elsewhere in your body which can be really good for your cancer.
So, think about other good natural anti-histamines large bark of course attend any anti inflammatory things that's what I would think of also you can do things on your skin to give you relief.
I would think of things like some we have some new tallow based creams that can be really good I would use a tallow.
You can also try a coconut oil you could try like a comfrey, a salve like a comfrey based salve maybe you mix that with a tallow I would try different things that will decrease the inflammation.
But almost always I mean one of these may help may help with this is doing the sauna so you have to test that out I would do if you have a sauna do short period of times with the sauna that could help with that too.
I was reading when doing a parasite cleanse lots of heavy metals are released into the system are they the tissue or the blood.
I don't know if I don't know how true that is or not.
The truth is that you know everybody has heavy metals in your tissues and the most common cell type that is going to harbor toxins chemicals poisons drugs heavy metals are fat cells.
So fat cells have I've always said that fat cells have the gift of accommodation they like welcome everybody in come on in stay here we have an extra room for you will make supper and breakfast with muffins the morning that's what fat cells do they're wonderful human beads and they allow everybody in no matter how bad your past is so
or I don't know I don't know that doing a parasite cleanse draws heavy metals or chemicals out I don't know that to be true.
If you end up with more circulating heavy metals remember they're going to be in the tissues they'll be in the cells.
They you will have some in the spaces between the cells that's called the extra cellular space but it typically won't stay there.
Your limb system is always attempting to clear that away and anything that goes into your limb system will eventually get to your Venus system circulates through your liver hopefully exits.
The bloodstream at the liver and then gets deposited into the bile after going through phase one and phase two detoxification in the liver and in the bile it goes down to the gallbladder and from the gallbladder goes to your duoden first part of the small intestine and from there hopefully will be deposited in your toilet without being reabsorbed in the large intestine that's why you would use binders.
So with any detoxification or even a parasite kill type program you want to go slow because you could overwhelm your liver and just circulate these things somewhere else you could overwhelm your gallbladder and that is the major cause of stone formation and gallbladder sluggishness.
And then you could if you're if your bowel movements aren't regular and healthy you could just be reabsorbing these things.
After my last cheek swap we increased beddaging to six per day my waky blood glucose is still low to mid-90s is there anything else I could do to get this down.
The burberry can be helpful I don't remember if you're taking burberry just about everybody could add burberry to their protocol if you heard me speak at any time I you know burberry is you know probably one of my if not my favorite supplement it's one of my favorite supplements.
Taking to a day of the burberry clear I think it's only 200 milligrams you know you could bump that up and that would be one thing to do just bump that up the reason why burberry is such a favorite supplement for somebody with cancer is because it does reduce your blood glucose levels.
And it is the one of the major killers of it's quite low right so it's just a great supplement all around and it's there's just a lot of research on burberry as a direct killer of cancer too so burberry is a great thing to take.
yeah so I would increase it I'd start by increasing it to four a day and see how give it a week or two and see if if that lowers your blood glucose at all you could go up to six or eight a day but if you're at that if you're at like eight a day and it's really that budget your blood glucose that I would probably back down back off again remember we're once your blood glucose we're.
Where is your blood glucose coming from your waking blood glucose coming from.
You didn't eat anything all that long you're fasting maybe you ate something at eight o'clock and then went to bed at 10 o'clock or something and you haven't eaten since eight o'clock pretend and your blood glucose is not coming from.
You it's coming from glycogen stores in your liver so your liver stores glucose in lung chains glucose molecules called glycogen and then it breaks down.
In the middle of the night through secretion of cortisol so cortisol think of that as a bad hormone oh my gosh cortisol is bad no everything is needed cortisol elevated cortisol still isn't bad it's an indicator of something it's indicator of adrenal stress but you need cortisol cortisol is created in the middle of the night to break down glycogen.
It's called stores well why do you need glucose in the middle of the night my muscles how you see that you know maybe somebody peoples are more than others if they're rushing around and better something but glucose is the primary fuel for the brain your brain fuels on glucose and oxygen glucose and oxygen is what runs your brain so your brain is working all night long.
Even though you're not solving problems of like you're doing in the middle of the day well truly your brain is solving problems all that your blood your brain is still just as active in the middle of the night isn't is in the daytime so you need glucose for that.
If you're if you're waking glucose was in the 60s and your daily you know if you did a 12 hour faster in the day and it was higher that would tell you that there's issues that you have issues with the adrenal fatigue and you need to support your adrenal glands so that they can make more cortisol at night in order to cause the breakdown of glycogen.
That's one of the issues that people have when they say I wake up in the middle of the night you know I tend to fall asleep just fine but then I wake up at 1 o'clock to go to the bathroom and I can't go back to sleep again I just what is wrong it takes me an hour to have to go back to sleep again.
That is a sign of overdose of sting and your drains are not kicking down a quarter of all to break down the glycogen stores or you know the Horror could be you don't have glycogen stores in your liver so the treatment for that is you need support your adrenal gland so that you can make enough cortisol because you need that breakdown so your brain isn't starving because the reason why you can go back to sleep is because.
you don't have the glycogen for your brain, so your body basically won't let you fall asleep.
So you have to get up and walk around and then you'll break down glycogen and create
glycogen breakdown through another pathway in order to fuel your brain. So if you can't go back
to sleep at one o'clock in the morning and you're later in bed with your eyes wide open, the best
thing you could do is get up and eat something right away. Get up and eat, you know, maybe some
little crackers or something. Some carbs so you get instant glucose to fuel your brain to help
you fall asleep or get up and walk around to break down glycogen in your liver. Another way is to
eat some protein before you go to sleep so you have, you know, you have some nutrients to
basically fuel your night time. Stay to sleep. What are your thoughts about? Guys,
a guy to step up for lower each other? Yes, there are some, we have some products in
what's it about? One product, I forgot, it's called Daya. There are some different products on
the market. Daxinal, diaxinal, that's the products, an ortho molecular product. And it has
a bordegel and buccal polysaccharides and heliorotic acid. There are multiple different products
to lower blood sugar. All of them are just fine. Chlobeon, picolinate is another one that was
really hot for a long time. So you can try those things too. I just like burberry because it has
some of the other side benefits. If you can't sleep, can you take a little honey? Yeah, so that would
be some carbs. Drinking some tea with some honey in it might be good. Help people back to sleep.
That's where I mean, in old days, your mother would give you a glass of milk and help you warm
milk, help you fall asleep. Why? Because your sugar unit gives you sugar for your brain to help
you fall back asleep. That's why stress is an issue that I can't sleep, but you have stress.
Because your cortisol is just bouncing all over or your cortisol levels have spiked because of
your stress all day. You're worried all day, your cortisol is just burned out and you're in a
adrenal fatigue at night and you don't have the cortisol to break down in the glycogen. And so
any other questions? All right, well, we will call it at night. Thank you guys for being on.
This will be up. So as I get uploaded to YouTube, all right. God bless you guys. Bye-bye.